after two months in the making and a lot
of political wrangling Israel now has a
new government the most far-right and
religiously conservative one in the
country's history despite a corruption
trial Benjamin Netanyahu returns as
prime minister thanks to a coalition of
an ultra-orthodox and nationalist block
heckling from opposition members in the
knesset didn't deter him from making his
message clear Israel's security
continues to be his top priority
we will guarantee Israel's military
advantage in the region through
unceasing empowerment the first mission
is to make sure that Iran won't
annihilate us with nuclear bombs also
high up on the agenda is the
normalization of relations with more
Arab countries under the 2020 Abraham
Accord that would sideline Palestinians
as the newly released government
guidelines highlight by saying the
Jewish people have an exclusive and
unquestionable right to all parts of the
land of Israel
netanyahu's new cabinet promises to
expand illegal settlements in the
occupied West Bank raising fears of an
escalation in tensions
[Music]
on a domestic level most controversially
Netanyahu is granting major concessions
to the far-right Coalition made up of
parties that until recently were still
on the political fringes
hundreds of anti-government protesters
gathered outside the knesset
demonstrating against some ministerial
appointments handed out including that
of etamir bengaver convicted of
incitement to racism in 2007 the now
security minister had a personalized law
passed in his name on Wednesday giving
him unprecedented Powers over the police
force other controversial laws Pass
include the dairy and smartrich laws the
first allowed Arya Dairy leader of the
Shas party to become the interior
Minister despite a recent suspended
sentence for tax fraud the latter giving
smart Rich head of the religious
designers and party a role within the
defense Ministry overseeing illegal
settlements in the occupied West Bank
critics are concerned that some of these
new policies will have far-reaching
consequences including the undermining
of the judicial system whereby the
Supreme Court could be overruled these
were all preconditions set by the
Coalition for the government to be sworn
in in the first place and we will
probably see a weekend Netanyahu because
his party is much weaker Visa V parties
like the religious Zionist because of
his a trial and because he has no
moderate party within the Coalition like
in the past this is the sixth government
in less than four years and Netanyahu
already has a lot on his plate with the
country at its most divided
Netanyahu is back as prime minister and
he says he will be the one setting the
agenda for the current government he
also says that red lines won't be
crossed and he won't be steered by what
he calls radical ideology bharti is
mostly in this position thanks to a
far-right coalition now the big question
is who will have the upper hand
Al Jazeera West Jerusalem